dynamic programming can come off as one
of those really intimidating subjects
but a lot of that confusion is actually
unwarranted the idea itself is
surprisingly simple and straightforward
as we're about to see
so to understand dynamic programming
let's try a horrible and super strained
real world analogy you work for me i'm a
great boss i ask you to do important
things so i call you in and i need you
to watch through seasons one and two of
rick and morty count up how many times
rick burps or something i don't know
anyway you figure you'll need about two
days to get this done i catch up with
you about two days later and at that
point i'm like actually you'll need to
check out seasons two and three instead
you're like alright i can have that done
by the end of today so what gives why so
much faster this time around and the
answer is blindingly obvious you already
did the work on season 2 as part of the
first task so you can focus just on
doing the new work this time around in
real life we just call this using your
common sense not like dynamic problem
solving or something like that i mean of
course you'd exaggerate it heavily on
your resume or promo packet or something
but that's kind of expected but in
programming we do give it an impressive
sounding name and a long wikipedia page
dedicated to it maybe even some greek
notation to really seal the deal and
when i say an impressive name that's not
an exaggeration on my part part of the
reason it was chosen was just it sounded
kind of cool so then let's talk about
what dynamic programming actually is
basically it's breaking down problems
into sub problems which in turn may
break into their own subproblems
solving those sub problems and
remembering the answers so that you
don't have to solve the same thing
multiple times that's it and there's
just a couple prerequisites for it to
kind of qualify as dynamic programming
those being that it has what's called
optimal substructure and the second
requirement is that it has overlapping
sub-problems
so having an optimal substructure means
that the substructure must be optimal
duh
okay now that i'm done being unhelpful
it just means that the optimal solution
to the problem has to be some
combination of the optimal solution of
its sub-problems or in other words if
you solve the sub-problems in the best
way possible you solve the main problem
so the second prerequisite for dynamic
programming to be applicable having
overlapping subproblems and all that
means is that when you're solving the
problem you're doing a lot of redundant
work solving the same problems over and
over again and of course those sub
problems that are getting redone they
have to be deterministic otherwise you
just can't save the result now let's
clarify memoization that is
memoization not memorization
but funnily enough that's basically what
we're doing it's essentially an
optimization whereby you don't just
compute the same thing over and over
again it's caching the return result of
some function and if you happen to call
that function again with the same
parameters bam you just return the
cached result instead
it's as easy as it sounds we could have
a function let's say that in code i've
got compute this stuff slowly and that
does some stuff memoization is just the
act of saving the return value so we
could have a memoized version that looks
kind of like this memoized compute this
stuff slowly blah blah blah blah blah
and that's it there's your memoized
version different languages might have
automatic ways of doing this but that's
basically it so don't overthink this
then you might have heard the term
tabulation mentioned in the same breath
and that's generally the same idea
except that with recursive solutions you
tend to work top down and with iterative
you tend to work bottom up working
towards the solution by building up from
smaller solutions typically by filling
out a table so tabulation is basically
just filling out an array or a table or
whatever with answers ahead of time
finally let's clarify top down versus
bottom-up because this often gets
confused in discussions people might
think that you start with top-down use
that to refine an answer and then build
an iterative approach and that's the
full thing or that the iterative version
is dynamic programming or something i
don't know there seems to be a lot of
confusion here to clarify they're just
two separate approaches both are dynamic
programming with a top down approach
you're doing exactly as the name implies
you're tackling the problem by breaking
it into multiple problems and then those
into ever smaller problems that need
solving etc etc in this old simpsons
episode they had a pigeon problem but it
turns out that bolivian tree lizards
love eating pigeons now to solve the
problem of their town being overrun by
lizards they simply need to release wave
after wave of chinese needle snakes then
to deal with the snakes they've lined up
a fabulous type of gorilla that thrives
on snake meat and finally when winter
rolls around the gorillas freeze to
death compare this to bottom-up solving
in that case you're working your way
towards the solution by solving smaller
easy-to-solve problems and using those
to piggyback towards harder ones hoping
to eventually solve the one you're after
let's go to the simpsons again here's
homer and he has this giant pile of
sugar as he kind of rambles into sleep
first you get the sugar then you get the
power then you get the women so he
started from the base case having a
giant pile of sugar and built up slowly
towards his final goal and this all kind
of mostly boils down to the difference
between having a recursive and an
iterative solution but the point is that
they're both dynamic programming two
different spins on the same idea
recursive solutions have their obvious
downsides like call depth and potential
for stack overflows but personally i
find it more intuitive to think this way
so i start with this approach iterative
has its own downsides in that you could
end up computing more than is necessary
to solve the problem at hand and i find
it personally less intuitive
so then how to solve these types of
problems
let's talk in somewhat abstract terms
here
so you've got this problem let's just
draw this circle up here and here's the
problem you're trying to solve so what i
tend to do is see if the answer at this
point can be expressed as some
combination of sub-problems and assuming
those sub-problems already solved then
those sub-problems in turn could be
expressed as some combination of already
solved sub-problems and so on
and a lot of these sub-problems at some
point they're computing the exact same
thing
if you imagine these nodes as function
calls maybe these two nodes here maybe
they have the exact same parameters
and maybe these other two have the same
parameters and so if they have the same
parameters and they're entirely
deterministic
then if we have some way of saving the
result and looking it up like we can
take the parameters and form a hash
table key for memoization then we can
just look up the results and once you
begin looking at it a bit like this you
may realize that the answers for a lot
of these dynamic programming problems
just kind of boil down to figuring out
how to sketch out this tree of states
but talk is cheap let's answer a
buttload of these fang style interview
questions in quick succession to show
you that a lot of them now not all of
them of course but many are basically
the exact same question but just wearing
a different hat starting with computing
the fibonacci sequence everyone's
favorite it's like the go-to example for
anybody explaining dynamic programming
and considering that there's an explicit
formula for calculating fibonacci seems
even more pointless to use dynamic
programming but yeah whatever let's do
it
anyway computing fibonacci at n it's
like the sum of fibonacci at n minus 1
plus fibonacci at n minus 2. you're
basically given the recursive definition
right away so here's the tree here's the
tip where you've got fibbit n and that
of course can be expressed as the
straight up sum of the two sub problems
fib n minus 1 and fib n minus 2. so
assuming you've got those you've got the
answer and those in turn each of those
depend on two more sums so you've got
fib n minus two and minus three and on
the other side n minus three and n minus
four so already crazy overlap this
entire tree for example is just a repeat
of this node here the code is dead
simple this isn't a tutorial on each
individual problem so i won't narrate it
but you can see here that i've got the
memoization code just save based on
parameters then you've got this
recursive step here which is basically
just a direct translation of what we
drew now here's the coin change problem
i'm just going to start blasting through
these you've got denominations of coins
like penny nickel dime quarter i'm
canadian a so we've also got loonies and
toonies but let's ignore those so the
objective is to figure out the minimum
number of coins to make a specific sum
so at the top of the tree that's the
full amount you can see that this could
be expressed as what if i used a quarter
or a dime or a nickel or a penny
what's the minimum number of coins to
make each of those new sums
and then each of those in turn would do
the same thing try to use a quarter a
dime a nickel or penny so the answer
then is whichever of these subsheets
gives the minimum number of coins plus
one so the code here notice how this is
damn near the same as the fibonacci
version but instead of summing up all
the values i loop over each one and take
them in
all right let's keep going here is the
zero one knapsack problem basically
you've got a knapsack with a capacity
and a bunch of items with weights and
values so how do you fill the knapsack
to maximize value again expressing this
starting at the top you got the backpack
full capacity and there's a bunch of
ways you can think about this easiest is
to basically say the two subtrees one
could be if you include the item and the
other is if you don't include the item
then each of these will in turn have
subtrees that consider the next item in
their list and to include it or not
include it so then it follows that for
the node that i do include the item the
capacity goes down and the node that i
don't include the item capacity stays
the same and the backpack at the top is
basically whichever of these two sub
backpacks maximizes the value plus
possibly the value of the item
so instead of doing a min we're doing a
max
here's the code we need to memorize
based on two parameters this time the
item index and capacity but the result
is super duper easy here's the staircase
problem you've got some number of stairs
you can either take one or two stairs at
a time how many different ways can you
climb up the stairs
well the top node you've got n stairs
you can only take one or two stairs to
have gotten there so the two sub trees
are 98 and 99 stairs
and repeating that same line of logic
you've got 96 97 97 or 98 stairs
and the total number of ways to get to
the top is just the sum of the total
number of ways to get to next to the top
again here's the code notice how this is
practically identical to the fibonacci
computation we did earlier it's almost
like i'm just doing minor edits on the
code here's the subset sum problem super
similar to the knapsack problem at the
top of the tree you've got the total sum
you're trying to make and each subtree
can either include or not include a
value pretty much exactly like the
knapsack one so the answer then is
basically if either of these subtrees is
true then the root is true so you're
doing an or and here's the code i'm
really hoping you're seeing a pattern to
these answers we just had to or the two
results together what the hell here's
the min path sum problem given a grid of
numbers starting at the top left corner
need to find a path where you can move
either right or down and you're trying
to minimize the sum of the values along
that path
again super similar to a previous
question the coin change one you can
either move right or down so starting at
the root node the base state you have
two possible moves and the min pass sum
is just the min of these two assuming
each of those figure out the min pass
sum to themselves
code is again super short
your min call your two recursive calls
where you attempt to either move right
or down and that's it so in general
there's a crazy amount of overlap to
these kind of questions they can be
super similar we just solved out a half
dozen of these in a couple minutes
now i'm not going to pretend the code in
these is like perfect or bug free or
even good
i did some superficial tests to see if
they got the answers right and we just
kind of cranked out the top down
versions you could turn around now and
use these to build out bottom-up ones
but the point being that really just
learn how similar these problems are
often they can be the same problem just
dressed up with different wording and
when you've got the right general
approach you can pound out the answers
to these types of questions so i get
this is all kind of possibly abstract
but a lot of these concepts are used
everywhere dynamic programming is in
essence breaking down a problem into
sub-problems and saving or pre-computing
answers to those sub-problems
and that sort of idea of kind of caching
the results of expensive calls or
pre-computing a bunch of stuff that sort
of memoization or tabulation pattern is
found everywhere
since this channel is more game
development oriented we'll stick to that
although an easy example to point out of
memoization is query caching in
databases to avoid having to re-query
the database over and over again but
looking into games there's a lot of old
school optimizations we could look at
like say for math and trigonometry where
you'd pre-compute trig values into a
lookup table and then use those instead
of actual trig calls maybe only useful
in kind of niche applications now but an
interesting historical note and lookup
tables or luts are essentially
tabulation tables they're a bunch of
pre-computed values and super popular
for graphics work
look at purlin and simplex noise in
shaders we often want to avoid doing all
that heavy alu work in the fragment
shader so what we can do is bake the
noise into textures and do a quick look
up instead
easy peasy lemon squeezy just cost a
texture fetch here's unreal using look
up tables to do color grading the idea
is that you bake a 3d texture and that
allows you to do a color transformation
with a simple lookup you can find the
exact same thing in three.js examples
here we can flip through different color
transformations easily using the
dropdown so this is pretty awesome
a lot of super advanced stuff also
depends on pre-computing storing and
lookups here's the atmospheric light
scattering implementation from sebastian
hilaire of epic games
see how much of it relies on
pre-computed textures to make it real
time or here are the horizon zero dawn
clouds which are kind of the standard
for clouds these days
this again relies on a lot of pre-baked
stuff into textures
anyway i might just be rambling at this
point it's late i'm tired and these
examples might be a bit strange but
hopefully you walk away from this with a
couple basic ideas
dynamic programming is just an
impressive name for some really basic
ideas those being that you can divide a
problem into smaller problems and by
solving those in the best way possible
you get the optimal answer for the main
problem and the second being just like
don't redo work you don't have to
hopefully that was helpful cheers